bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du beh suivent
ce mois ci dans notre dossier nous vous
présentons la vie associative de
l'université
et nous revenons ensuite sur les
événements qui ont fait l'actualité du
mois
enfin portrait de fabien jobard
directeur du centre de recherches
sociologiques sur les institutions et le
droit pénal est tout de suite le
micro-trottoir bons numéros à tous
l'événement de dubé deux affaires a
fortiori choix sur une soirée au 15 15
c'était une soirée étudiante et voilà
une association spécialisée spéciale
enfin fait monter par des étudiants
d'histoire qui s'appelle agora il
organise très souvent des soirées pour
réunir les étudiants et ils font ils
font même un journal me semble bon à
l'hôpital des nounours on s'est rendu
compte que certains enfants aient peur
du médecin simplement parce qu'il
portait une blouse blanche donc c'est un
premier élément de sensibilisation la
soirée étudiante en fait qui est
organisé annuellement tous les ans donc
je voudrais me organise souvent des
soirées ou des événements à la fac celui
qui m'a le plus marqué cette année c'est
la soirée qu'on a organisé pour la fin
du concours des premières années de
médecine donc c'était un événement à 950
personnes au gibus et c'était génial
c'était une ambiance de folie
il ya trente associations actuellement à
l'université
elles se répartissent en association à
thématique ou généraliste et en
association de filière
les associations thématiques aborde des
thèmes comme le développement durable et
l'environnement la solidarité le social
également les loisirs ou encore le
théâtre
un label association agréée active a été
créé pour valoriser les associations qui
créent des projets sur l'université ou
encore avec les partenaires extérieurs
mais pour les étudiants
chaque année le forum associatif de mai
top départ de l'année associative il
permet aux étudiants de se rencontrer et
d'échanger sur leurs projets
depuis l'année dernière s'est enrichi
d'une journée festive qui propose aux
étudiants toutes sortes d'animations
la direction de la vie étudiante propose
des formations associative qui
permettent aux étudiants de se former
sur les thèmes comme la méthodologie de
projet le financement le bilan moral et
financier
et encore la prévention des risques
le rôle d'une présidente de
l'association il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord c'est encadrer une équipe
puisqu'on fait partie d'un bureau où il
ya président trésorier secrétaire des
fois des vice présidents donc c'est se
mettre en accord avec les différentes
parties pour organiser les différents
projets et puis au delà au delà de ça
recruter de nouveaux membres les
investir dans certains projets qui
peuvent les intéresser et après tout ce
qui est paperasse demandé auprès de la
fac des subventions faire des
partenariats avec d'autres personnes
d'autres organismes d'autres
associations pour mener à bien des
projets
ce qui m'a poussée de présidence et au
final investir dans des choses qui me
plaisait mais projet qui me plaisait
mais aussi rencontrer différentes
personnes qui venaient de différentes
filières parce que généralement on
arrive à la fac on est avec les gens de
de sa promo pour mange avec les gens de
sa promo sort avec les gens de sa promo
et au final à tout plein de filières
différentes et des personnes qui peut
d'en apprendre sur différents sujets
ça sera clientes ont surtout un lieu de
rencontre ici on a un campus qui est
assez assez éclatée qui est assez qu'une
vie étudiante or qui est présente mais
sur lesquels les turnes ils vont pas
forcément d'entrée de jeu s'intéresser à
léo soirée allait aux événements se
raconte et donc la tradition c'est un
peu ça peu le trait d'union c'est aussi
une façon de
te voir un peu autrement dévoile une
gare c'est autrement plus que autrement
que comme juste l'envoi où on va prendre
ses cours c'est quoi
d'autre d'autres fassent d'autres
d'autres compétences et qui du coup
effectivement de se valoriser sur un sur
un cv
pour la recherche d'emploi
notre éviter de mantes en yvelines
propose pour la rentrée prochaine une
nouvelle licence professionnelle
intitulé véhicules électriques et
électromobilité qui se concentre sur la
place de la voiture électrique en ville
cette formation proposée en
apprentissage est soutenu par la
fondation renault alors un partenariat
avec l'iut de menton yvelines parce que
le lancement industriel delà des
véhicules électriques par renault n'est
pas simplement une affaire industrielle
ni technologique c'est aussi la
formation des hommes aux métiers qui
accompagneront justement céder cette
émergence de l'électromobilité
découvrez toutes les informations sur
cette licence sur le tout nouveau site
internet de l'iut de mantes en yvelines
l'ufr des sciences accueillait sur
plusieurs demi-journées des lycéens pour
leur faire découvrir les études
scientifiques dans l'enseignement
supérieur les élèves ont ainsi pu
assister à quelques expériences de
physique de quoi peut-être leur donner
envie de poursuivre leurs études à
l'université
ces demi journées sont l'une des
nombreuses actions menées dans le cadre
des cordées de la réussite
alors les cordées de la réussite c'est
une opération qui vise à rapprocher
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur d
des collégiens de la région qui entoure
l'établissement en question donc pour
nous l'université reste un peu des
lycéens de guyancourt de trappes de
maurepas voilà tous ces établissements
sont concernés
l'université a accueilli ce mois ci la
9e édition de l'atelier tune vih ps une
série d'ateliers destinés aux
développeurs d'applications
organisé pour la première fois en france
ce rassemblement vise spécifiquement
l'optimisation des codes notamment sur
le supercalculateur curie ici on a des
cours parallèles qui tourne en parallèle
sur plusieurs corse par est tombé sur
une centaine ou
peut-être même sur des milliers de
coeurs et après le but et c'est
d'optimiser le code pour qu'elle puisse
tourner plus vite
à l'occasion de la sortie de son livre
le sens du peuple le professeur en
sciences politiques laurent bouvet animé
une conférence afin de présenter son
nouvel ouvrage
dans ce livre explique deux choses je
reviens un peu sur la définition du
peuple en politique puisque c'est un
sujet assez compliqué en fait qu'on ne
sait pas exactement qui est le peuple
qu'il ya dedans que fait le peuple donc
j'essaie de voir un petit peu quelles
sont les différentes définitions de
cible et puis ensuite je regarde le
rapport entre le peuple politique et la
gauche en france et la manière dont la
gauche dans les dernières années depuis
disons 30 40 ans a abandonnés ou laissés
tomber le peuple au sens général et en
particulier au sens des catégories
populaires
c'est tout pour les news de ce mois ci
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez suivre
toute l'actualité de l'université sur
notre facebook notre twitter ou sur
www.beille.fr
ski fabien jobard
chercheur au cesdip qu'est le centre de
recherches sociologiques sur le droit et
les institutions pénales
je suis docteur en sciences politiques à
l'origine j'avais fait une thèse sur la
police et puis petit à petit je me suis
spécialisé sur les matières policière
elle a le contrôle social et
spécialisation qui m'a amené petit à
petit à
m'intégrer au cesdip et puis à en être
le directeur depuis 2010 après le bac
j'ai intégré sciences po à paris et puis
j ai fait toutes mes études
et puis après sciences po je l'étais à
terre pendant deux ans à
l'université de rouen et puis je suis
parti en allemagne pendant quatre ans où
j'étais post-doc là bas où j'ai passé le
concours cnrs et puis j'ai intégré le
cesti pas mon retour à mon retour
d'allemagne en 2002
le cesdip c'est un laboratoire qui a
deux particularités
d'abord c'est un laboratoire en sciences
sociales qui est spécialisée les
laboratoires en sciences sociales sont
souvent très
pluri thématiques nous on est très
spécialisé sur les questions pénales qui
peut au sens large c'est-à-dire de la
prévention de la délinquance en passant
par la police et en allant jusqu'à la
prison l'exécution des peines et star
deuxième particularité du cesdip c'est
que c'est un laboratoire qui a trois
tutelles en fait le cnrs l'université
et le ministère de la justice
on a engagé une coopération avec la
faculté de médecine
autour des thématiques médico légal on
examine aujourd'hui les résultats d'une
première recherche sur les victimes de
violence qui se présentent à l'institut
médico judiciaire et puis on essaie de
mettre en place des dispositifs
d'observation des violences par exemple
les services d'urgence hospitaliers je
m'étais fait
l'un des champs de recherche de l'âme
du cesdip c'est ce qu'on appelle dans un
certain nombre de pays étrangers la
criminologie en pro plein de raisons
historiques la criminologie s'est pas
développée en france en france on a eu
deux branches de savoir qui ont traité
ces matières la la sociologie des
sciences sociales et puis
l'autre branche sont toutes les sciences
du psychisme psychologie psychiatrie
psychanalyse alors aujourd'hui il ya un
débat très vif en français dans le
cesdip et acteur
c'est sur l'éventuelle
institutionnalisation de la criminologie
est ce qu'on va créer une discipline
universitaire qui serait la criminologie
et on y est hostile paradoxalement parce
que
la criminologie
c'est si vous voulez un champ de
discipline au pluriel qui dialoguent
dans un espace commun avec un objet
commun qui est le crime le crime sa
prévention son traitement sa répression
si on veut faire de la criminologie une
science unique c'est-à-dire une science
qui soit la synthèse de la sociologie et
des sciences du psychisme
on va dans le mur on va dans le mur
parce qu'on a une approche à ce
moment-là scientiste de cet objet qu'est
le crime et puis on va dormir parce
qu'on en a l'expérience historique ça a
toujours échoué
merci de nous avoir suivi on se donne
rendez vous en juillet pour un nouveau
numéro
d'après
le nom c'est bientôt ouais